I'm at the Computer History Museum in Mountain
View, California,
and amongst all the thousands of artifacts
here is this:
a regular, everyday teapot.
The world's most famous teapot.
It's called the Utah Teapot, and you've almost
certainly seen it before,
even if you don't realise it.
Or at least, a digital version of it.
In the old Windows Pipes screensaver,
occasionally instead of a ball joint,
a teapot would appear.
This teapot.
It's in the background of that 3D-animated
Simpsons episode from the 90s,
and it's in a couple of Pixar films.
It's an in-joke amongst animators,
and that's because it was the first realistic,
complex object
to be widely used in computer graphics.
In 1974, a researcher at the University of
Utah called Martin Newell
needed a reference object, something simple
to test the algorithms he was designing.
The story goes that he told his wife this
as they were sitting down for tea --
Newell was born in Britain, so tea --
and she suggested that modelling the teapot.
And it was ideal.
It has concave and convex surfaces.
It can cast shadows on itself,
which is a problem that some algorithms might
find difficult to solve.
It's immediately recognisable:
you can tell by eye if the teapot looks like
a teapot,
or if something's gone wrong with your rendering.
And you don't have to texture it to make it
look good.
As long as it has a plain, light colour, and
it...
well, it... it looks like a teapot.
But it's also not too complicated: back in
the seventies,
computer graphics involved a lot of working
by hand.
Newell sketched the teapot on graph paper,
and then typed in the resulting coordinates
by hand.
And here's what I really like about the teapot:
over the forty-something years that the digital
version of it has existed,
details about it have been lost to history.
It's said that it was used so much for early
graphics experiments
that some people could remember all of its
data in their head
and just type it in when they needed it.
Can I find a reliable source for that?
Absolutely not,
but it's a great story.
And at some point, the teapot got squished
a bit:
some people claim that it's because of old
displays with non-square pixels,
and some claim it's just because it looked
better that way.
This is a artifact of the digital era that's
got urban legends around it.
And whether they're true or not,
there's now a canonical version of the teapot:
a digital object that's been copied and copied
and copied into all sorts of modern culture.
Literally billions of people have seen -- well,
not this teapot --
but a version of it that can be described
in one page of numbers.
Thanks very much to the Computer History Museum
in Mountain View, California!
Pull down the description for links to them
and the amazing exhibits they've got here.